oh yeah my name is Anthony Gray's I'm a
exonerees number 138 here in the state
of Texas I was wrongfully convicted I
spent 18 1/2 years in prison twelve and
a half for Texas death row I had two
execution dates and I came within just
like about 45 days so I wasn't just in
that state of panic because my execution
dates were premature I hadn't even even
exhausted my appeals before they started
trying to execute me so which is why my
and my attorneys wasn't in a state of
panic at that point but nevertheless had
the system continue to fail me that it's
more than likely on one of those day
they would affect executed me but you
know I had to go to tarnish that was
vigilant and and understood the the
process and you know so I got to stay of
executions until my innocence to approve
them but yeah it was a nightmare for 18
and a half years well yes you say you
weren't in a state of panic what kind of
state were you and what was it like to
be on death row well you know I mean you
know anyone can ask that question but
you can't even you know I don't think
you're prepared for the answer because
it is what I will always tell people you
your worst nightmare whatever you think
your nightmare is I lived that for six
thousand six hundred and forty days you
know I was in solitary confinement 16
and a half for the 18 years that they
they had me incarcerated
I witnessed over 350 to 400 men getting
executed around me guys that I got to
know and love like brothers you know
guys that I seen that had mental health
issue illness issues guys who cases were
didn't didn't deserve to be a definitely
qualified case guys who are actually
innocent
I witnessed all of that through you know
at the same time facing my own mortality
in terms of thought that they could
execute me for something I did not
commit you know crime I didn't do so it
was just chaotic it was nightmarish uh
you know I witnessed me and hanging
themselves attempting to hang themselves
banana peels because they just wanted to
get away from the whole situation I
witness man just going crazy uh cutting
their throats are slit their wrists self
mutilating themselves uh one man said no
Texas death row now
snatch this aisle swallowed it you know
I mean the the conditions just literally
driving me insane
it's totally inhumane and that's what
they're practicing how did you cope when
you were released well I mean you know
I'm the exception not the rule I ask
people not to look at me because for
some reason I I've managed to just quite
well I mean I think that's because I I
never gave up on my freedom so that
allowed me to still be free even even
while incarcerated which was which is
all you know a a mind game with itself
you know but I mean I am the exception
because I'm doing quite well I mean it
wasn't it wasn't just easy as
one-two-three I mean you know that was
telson that I had to take to get to
where I'm at now because I dealt with
bouts of PTSD you know where I just
didn't know if I could make it out here
because I had been so disconnected from
the world it had changed on me it's 20
years and so I come into a totally
different world like just being dropped
off on Mars you know enough I didn't
know nothing I mean I had no routine I
had no friends to talk to it you know
when the whole world was sleeping I
couldn't sleep because I was still
dealing with sleep deprivation and uh so
I'll be up all night you know crying
waiting on the world to wake up just so
I can feel a part of it again and at
some points you know I would ask myself
man are you really gonna make it out
here you know but those are things that
those are the weaker moments you know
and and I had to fight through those
things you know so what I did is I I
started seeking therapy
I wouldn't seeing the counsellor council
can help me she cried more than I did
because she just couldn't understand him
inhumanity of it all and so then I
decided to take it to the stage and
share my experience with the world which
is now why I travel the world and speak
abroad about our need for criminal
justice reform and why the death penalty
cannot work you know I've created my
one-man stage there's now crisscross the
country with now Jay
educate the masses about our need for
reform and why the death penalty
shouldn't exist in a civilized society
so i I've taken my life back
by using the audience around the world
as my theory and it has helped me
tremendously well Anthony grace we
appreciate you sharing your experiences
with us tonight thanks very much indeed